right wingers are flying off the handle
because military dad ki zircon the
father of deceased army captain who
Mayan Khan said on an Arabic language
channel that Allah God is causing Donald
Trump to make mistakes dunya news
reported that the father of uh US
soldier whom I in con said that
Republican presidential candidate Donald
Trump is unacceptable to the US and that
Allah makes people like Trump make
mistakes to discredit them in the public
eyes forever right-wingers are going not
saying look at this extremist talking
about Allah saying Allah wants Trump to
lose I hate to break it to you but this
is no different than George W Bush
saying God told him to invade Iraq this
is no different than Ted Cruz or Ted
Cruz's wife or Ben Carson saying God
told them to run for president if you
believe that people claiming their God
said things about politics is ridiculous
then it's ridiculous no matter what name
you use for God and that's what's
amazing to me louis the same
right-wingers who seem to take no issue
with Ted Cruz saying God told me to run
for president are saying it's wrong that
kids are con thinks God wants to expose
Donald Trump is a charlatan if you
believe one is ridiculous you have to
believe the other is ridiculous the fact
that their word for God is Allah doesn't
change that reality yeah and if you
think that one is legitimate uh in this
case maybe you're not thinking the other
one is legitimate because if you're
Christian you're thinking Islam isn't
real I suppose if you're a devout Muslim
you thinking Christianity isn't real so
there's that people are criticizing cuz
ur con because he allegedly stands to
make money from Muslim immigration to
the US through a law firm that he's
associated with it's an allegation right
uh of whether it's true or not it
changes absolutely nothing about the
hypocrisy of saying he's an extremist
because he believes his God is playing a
role in American politics but none of
the Republicans who believe that God is
playing a role in American politics are
extremist you can't justify the two
there's absolutely no justification for
believing that one is crazy and the
other makes perfect sense and this is an
unfair criticism of mr. Khan no matter
what else is true about a law firm that
he may or may not be associated with